hello everyone and welcome to another
game from round nine the last round of
the Greinke just classic 2019 we
mentioned we're going to show another
game as we do have to show the standings
and of all the games I'd show I've
chosen this one as I won't show as much
games as possible
play by by a young Vincent climber and
this one is well really interesting so I
do hope you enjoy it we do have some
nice footage from the Greinke just
classic video team so let's enjoy that
for a brief moment here we have some
nice footage of Paco a relatively short
one but you know we we work with what we
have and here we have some footage of
Vincent there you have it adjusting the
brightness seems to be there we go it's
a bit of a longer clip but the camera
will zoom out so you can also see the
position there you go all right so I do
hope you enjoyed that now let's check
out the game it's really interesting
really really enjoyable benoni so let's
just check it out
Kaymer has the white pieces and he opens
with d4 it seems that the camera opens
every game with the d4 wood white and I
really like that because he's very young
and he wants a fight so he basically
says black can choose whatever system he
wants to play with Knight to f6 c4 well
now we have E six Knight to f3 and c5 so
preparing the the Benoni
d5 and now d6 first not capturing
immediately Knight to c3 e capture Sundy
5c captors on d5 and we have the sender
setup of the benoni defense g6 by Paco
with h6 and now Bishop to g7 and the
Vincent that goes for this now pretty
much the most popular line against the
benoni which goes with h3 e4 and Bishop
to d3 so e for defending the d5 pawn
also grabbing more space in the center
with castles by Paco and now Bishop to
d3 we have a 6 by black preparing some
expansion on the Queen side and a for
Vincent prevents this nights the h5 now
hoping to get this f5 move in while in
skiing is still in the center and the
Vincent doesn't allow it
he plays g4 that doesn't really care
about the missing ups the pawn structure
in front of his king as black already or
also Castle kingside we have night back
lift six by Paco and now Bishop to f4 a
nice developing move the bishop also has
a safe square and g3 now and the d6 pawn
might be a bit of a nuisance for Black
Cats white might decide to go for for
some maneuvers like Knight d2 to c4 the
pressure the d6 pawn but with Knights th
now preparing f5 this way and the g4
also works as a you know further
insurance that black doesn't play f5 and
here there is one game in the database
where Quinta e 2 was played but here
will Queen to d2 by Vincent and now we
have a completely new game on our hands
so nice to d7 with ideas of maybe going
nice to e5 but also with ideas of
pushing c4 and going nice to see 5 and
here you could go for Bishop h6 right
away but then Queen to f6 is a bit of a
problem for white as the knight on f3 is
undefended due to this g4 move and now
if captures then black is faster you're
already threatening to capture the rook
on h1 would check so Vincent first
castles and now h5 and here it's a very
interesting moment who's busting who's
defenses here with h5 is is a white
under attack here or black well we'll
just have to see we have G captures on
h5 and now not capturing immediately but
first nice to e5 threatening Knight
captures on f3 the night is still
undefended which would lose white the
Queen so Vincent has to react to this we
have Knight captures on e5 d captures on
e5 and now Bishop to g5 attacking the
Queen here f6 by black pushing the
bishop back Bishop to e3 and now you
don't have a couple of options to choose
from
you could go Bishop captures on h3 you
could go G captures on h5 but Paco goes
for the for the most interesting line
and it's one of the reasons why I also
decided to show this game c4 and here
Vincent has to make a choice does he
wants to go does he want to go back with
Bishop to e2 which seems to be the
safest choice or does he want to capture
see for grabbing more material and
allowing Knight to d6 and more activity
for black Vincent decides to go for the
for the bravest choice
Bishop captures on c4 and now comes
Knight to d6 attacking the bishop here
and now again Vincent has to make a
choice does he wants to go back and go
for this Bishop captures an h3 line rook
e1 + f5 giving black a whole lot of
activity or does he want to go for the
one that he chose Queen to e2 just
defending the bishop here and now again
it's not only defending the bishop but
it's also an attacking move because if
Paco decides to go for Bishop captures
on h3 now you go H captures on g6 and
you have this very clear path to victory
and black it will it will be very hard
for blacks to defend this so after Queen
to e2 Paco doesn't waste time with this
Bishop captures on h3 idea rather he
goes f5 and now you don't have time for
this if you go for this now then you get
Queen to h4 and now what do you do if he
captures on f5 just Bishop captures on
f5 and after Bishop to d3 it's hard to
defend your Queen constantly has to
depend on this Bishop after Bishop d3
you get E for and now after you go back
just rook to f6 rope or capture on g6
and this game will game over for white
so vincent cannot go for for any slow
place here after f5 here vincent plays
f4 and Paco just jumps in into the
attack with the Queen Queen to h4 and
now again your queen is still protecting
this Bishop here you don't really have a
good way of defending the h3 pawn Queen
to g3 check isn't is an idea so this is
how vincent goes about he plays Bishop
to c5 just pins that night as the rook
is still on f8 but it's not really
pinning it since if if not if Knight
captures Bishop and the Queen is not
protecting it then it's a problem you
will win two bishops for a rook which is
not something you want to do but there
was no better way here Quinta g3 was
played by Paco and now if you defend it
now it's just two bishops for a rope you
can just exchange Queens Knight captures
and now after captures you will simply
capture here and you've won two bishops
for a rook which is of course
better for decided that and grab the two
bishops so here Vincent decides to go
King to H one and now we have just King
Queen captures on h3 and here's the
problem now Vincent loses another pawn
and he has to block with the Queen the
problem is he can't repeat moves here
because Queen g3 jerking each one Paco
will not repeat Queen h2 richer he will
go Queen to h4 check and after King g1e
captures on f4 and now after Bishop
captures and b6 yes you do win the night
and attack the rook but here comes
Bishop to d4 check rook has the block
and now F captures on e4 and you get
this massive attack for a few for for
just a piece basically and it will be
very hard for white to defend here for
example if you grab the rook then it's
over Queen g3 check King f1 and now even
Bishop to h3 check is coming king e1 not
just Bishop captures with check captures
captures with check King D to clean d1
or even better than that just blocking
with the Queen you have to make some
room for it King Queen captures with
check Queen to d1 not just Queen capture
screen captures and rook captures Bishop
defending the pawn here and now you have
to connect the past points you are up
two points and it will be an easily
winning endgame for black so the few
options that are here aren't all that
great for Vincent so Vincent decides
just to block with the Queen and now
Paco just grabs the Queen and the two
bishops with Queen captures on h2 King
captures and now Knight captures on c4
Bishop captures on f8 King captures on
f8 and now H captures on g6 by Vincent
it's a very nice pawn but you know you
still you're still down to bishops for a
rook eek a purse on f4 with he captures
an f5 Bishop captures on f5 and now rook
a to e1 and Paco doesn't mind he wants
to trade rooks and enjoy his bishop pair
would white having as well as few the
pieces on the board as possible rook
captures on e8 King capture Sonny a rook
e1 check and now just the Bishop to e5
seems like a blunder because b3 can just
kick away the defender of the bishop but
then 93 and you're still not gaining
anything along the e-file so with Knight
the d1
now defending the pawn here and also if
if 93 the knight can capture it now but
Bishop captures and g6 popcorn up grabs
even more material and now you can see
that the two bishops are simply too
powerful King to g2 with Bishop to c2
and the now King to f3 we have kinked
the d7 getting out of the e-file and now
Knight to f2 with King to d6 and now
comes Luke the c1 attacking the bishop
but now just Knights the e3 and it was
in this position unmoved 36 before even
reaching tank control that Vincent
camera resigned the game even though he
had over 5 minutes on the clock and Paco
head or I believe a minute and a half
but it's enough this position place
itself Kings just gonna grab the d5 pawn
then you're just gonna pick up all the
other points here and White has no
counter play let's say 94 check you just
pick it up Knight c3 King c4 you're
gonna go to b3 you're gonna win the b2
pawn and it's all over
so after this Knight e3 move vincent
resigned the game and a very nice
victory for for Paco here who played a
brilliant attacking game especially
since he chose that line with C forward
Vincent had to make a choice whether he
wants to go Bishop e2 or capture on c4
he just fell out black a lot of activity
and all of a sudden without even knowing
where white went wrong found himself
under under losing the side of this
attack which is what usually happens
when you play against the benoni
if you don't play it play well against
the benoni but yeah now that's the game
I do hope you enjoyed it and we do have
the standings after the final round and
I made a mistake in the previous video I
told you that maxime beaugeois gravity
magnus carlsen first with seven and a
half then Fabiano corona with six and
then arc a denied each has a better
additional criteria so he's third with
five points then maxime beaugeois grab
then three of them with four and a half
which Manhattan Anand Peter Sadler 11
onion and then Francisco of Vallejo
ponds with four and then guru Meier and
Vincent Kaymer
with two points so it seems Vincent
finish finished last but he did he did
grab two points and it's not just any
two points he he won a game against Gil
Meyer
and also drew games against 11 Arden and
Peter Svidler
if you if you draw against Peter Svidler
in level Oregon doesn't matter what you
do with the rest of your games it's
still a great tournament especially for
for Vincent who is well about 300
reading rating points low rated than
anyone else here and you know 100 rating
points lower rated as I don't know
Garrick Mayer is 2600 and the Vincent is
2500 so even Myer is almost 200 rating
points lower rated than everyone else
and Vincent is even 100 rating points
lower rated Dan Meyer so I think two
points out of out of nine is an
excellent excellent achievement for for
young Vince but yeah once again that's
the game I do hope you enjoyed it and I
would like to thank Charles cotton
Miguel Martinez choppa and berry McMurdo
Charles Automan and Daniel binder for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check - in my previous
videos sierra think Oh for watching and
I will see you soon
continuing the Capablanca saga as we do
have to finish that a few more games in
the in the rice tournament in New York
and then we are perhaps checking up
another tournament we'll see about that
and then we're going to Lasker vs.
couple monka the match yeah I think oh I
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day